hoy
[Aplausos]
[Música]
cuando observamos un arco iris ocurre un
fenómeno bastante curioso y es que si
bien vemos diferentes colores en
realidad se trata del mismo haz de luz
que va variando su longitud de onda
eso significa que entre el azul el rojo
o el violeta hay sólo una diferencia de
grado de magnitud
y este fenómeno siempre me pareció muy
interesante porque refleja bastante bien
lo que ocurre en el campo de la salud
mental
porque entre la felicidad y los
trastornos mentales que parecen cosas
muy distintas hay sólo una diferencia de
grado
las personas nos saltamos de un estado a
otro y tampoco estamos estancadas en un
color sino que continuamente nos vamos
moviendo entre un polo y otro
y como investigador y psicoterapeuta
siempre me interesó conocer cuál en los
factores que generaron esos movimientos
y desde hace 10 años junto a un equipo
de investigación nos pusimos a
estudiarlos y encontramos que aunque los
factores sociales económicos o genéticos
son factores de importancia nuestra
manera de pensar es crucial
y pensamos y como lo pensamos determina
en gran medida cómo lo vamos a sentir y
cómo nos vamos a comportar
seguramente todos conocen a alguien no
tiene un amigo que se encuentra en el
polo del bienestar
esas personas que están siempre bien de
buen humor siempre contentas ya hasta te
indigna porque
así como hace años pasa un amigo de la
infancia el mate
como hace para estar siempre bien
pero cuando te pones a analizar sus
patrones de pensamiento empiezas a
entender por qué
el matí por ejemplo cuando tenía un
problema lo primero que hacía era
ponerlo en perspectiva
analizar cuál iba a ser el impacto real
de ese problema en su vida si realmente
valía la pena prestar la atención
y en caso en que sea un problema
interesante lo que hacía el materia
focalizarse en los planes
pensar la forma de resolverlo
hoy aceptamos
yo en cambio exactamente lo opuesto
cuando tengo un problema lo primero que
hago es catástrofes arlo
agrandar las consecuencias negativas de
ese problema es más ni siquiera hace
falta que tenga un problema yo ante la
duda catastrófico
esto esto es un granito o un tumor
entonces lo que hago es voy a google y
pongo bulto en la cara cáncer a ver qué
encuentro
la tendencia catastrófica y focalizarnos
en los negativos es un patrón de
pensamiento muy común pero no es el
único de hecho hay personas que además
tienden a culpabilizar a otros por lo
que creen que están pasando son los
famosos externalizan test se los
denomina así porque se la agarran con la
persona que tienen alrededor son
personas que tienden a estar enojadas o
frustradas lo que pasa que claro a ver
están rodeadas de inútiles es que la
gente hace todo mal porque yo no me
explico viste cómo maneja la gente no
presta atención encima lo volvió parece
que se sincronizarán pérez a la misma
hora
pero yo no entiendo por qué el estado no
hace nada porque no gestiona los boludos
o sea porque no hay un carril así la
gente normal va con tranquilidad
también están los internalizan test son
personas que catástrofes han tienden a
focalizarse lo negativo pero en vez de
culpar a otros se autoinculpan
yo por ejemplo forma parte del club
me pasó cuando estaba armando la charla
voy a arrancar con una metáfora de un
arco iris como que cada color es un
estado emocional como que el rojo la
depresión para el rojo es parte del arco
iris seguro que todo el mundo sabe
cuáles son los colores de arcoiris - yo
ya veo que en el público de un experto
un arco iris que se para y me dice no
flaco te equivocaste el rojo no está el
arco iris
también tuvo una idea bárbara que digo
bueno no para motivarme
voy a entrar a youtube a ver los vídeos
de ted así me motivó
y puse una charla y encontré charlas muy
buenas
y no podía evitar pensar echarles una
que no tendría nada de malo pero el
problema es que ese pensamiento suele
venir acompañado de una sensación de
auto desprecio
como si el hecho de no hacer las cosas
bien me quitara valor como persona me
hiciera menos creíble
esto es bárbaro para el autoestima no
y ustedes dirán que leo no te conviene
pensar como tu amigo matías
pero no es voluntario no es que yo me
levanto y digo bueno tengo un ratito
libre voy a poner a catastróficas
es algo que ocurre de forma automática
lo que pasa es que estos patrones de
pensamiento son patrones muy antiguos
que en algún momento sirvieron para la
supervivencia de nuestra especie
y que provienen de una región de nuestro
cerebro que no controlamos de forma
voluntaria
por eso se llaman pensamientos
automáticos son como reflejos que tienen
nuestro cerebro
y se preguntarán si tiene algo de malo
si tengo estos pensamientos
investigaciones que hemos hecho junto a
colegas españoles indican que las
personas que tienen dificultad para
regular estos patrones de pensamiento
son más proclives a tener desórdenes
emocionales
lo que hace estos pensamientos es que
emociones saludables y normales como
estar enojado o con miedo o estresado se
vuelvan un poco más intensas y más
crónicas
y es este el factor
qué afecta a nuestra salud física y
mental
no van a observar cambios abruptos por
tener estos pensamientos pero poco a
poco se van llevando de un polo al otro
qué pasa si el estrés normal saludable
se empieza a volver más crónico
bueno los primeros síntomas de malestar
que vas a experimentar son de una
tensión generalizada te sentís como
acelerado esta es tan tensionado que te
cuesta relajarte te cuesta dormir
estás tan tensionado que puede ser que
tengas dolores de espalda con el cuello
estás tan tensionado que una área de tu
cerebro que se ocupa del control
inhibitorio empieza a fallar
para empezar a notar cómo es que estás
sin filtro
como que decir las cosas más
directamente como que estás un poquitito
más irritable
vamos a empezar a tener problemas de
concentración porque no puedes mantener
la atención focalizada en un punto
y empezar a tomar malas decisiones
simplemente porque no te pudiste detener
a pensar bien lo que ibas a hacer
y si el estrés sigue en el tiempo
bueno empiezan a aparecer síntomas de
agotamiento
te levantas y te sentís cansado
volvés del trabajo y te sentís inah
energía estás tan cansado que sentís que
no tenés energía ni siquiera para hacer
cosas que te gustan como estar con tus
hijos o hacer actividad física
y según nuestras investigaciones un 41%
de los trabajadores en argentina
experimentó estos síntomas la mayor
parte de los días de la semana
y si la estrés continúa creciendo
empiezan a aparecer síntomas de sí
mismos
empiezas a sentir como que tu trabajo
tiene sentido cabe este sentir menos
involucrado con tu trabajo cada vez te
cuesta más disfrutarlo
te empieza a importar todo muy poco
estás tan cansado que ya te da lo mismo
si lo haces bien o mal se lo denomina
estado de sí mismo porque sabes que lo
estás haciendo mal pero ya no te importa
y según nuestras investigaciones un 22
por ciento de los trabajadores en
argentina experimenta estos síntomas y
esto es un problema serio
porque los trabajadores son el sector de
la población que más contribuye al
desarrollo de una comunidad
y si ese sector no cuenta con cierto
bienestar no puede afrontar las demandas
laborales cotidianas no puede tolerar el
estrés normal no puede desarrollar su
talento
y esto es un problema para el trabajador
para la organización y para todos
nosotros
y si el estrés continúa creciendo
empiezan a aparecer dificultades para
experimentar emociones positivas
cada vez te cuesta más estar de buen
humor o estar entusiasmado
y esto viene acompañado de una reducción
de actividad
pero no por cansancio por desmotivación
y estos síntomas son la puerta de
entrada a la depresión
uno de los trastornos más
discapacitantes y prevalentes del mundo
para los catástrofes adores de la sala
no se alarmen si están experimentando
estos síntomas
afortunadamente son todos tratables y
reversibles
y tampoco se sienten un raro si
tienen estos patrones de pensamientos
son naturales son reflejos que tiene el
cerebro que a veces nos juegan una mala
pasada
lo que pasa es que es tan fácil quedarse
debido a esos pensamientos
pero podemos aprender a tomar conciencia
y a gestionarlos lo cual va a demandar
esfuerzo y práctica
de hecho hay ni idea que no ayuda y es
la de pensar que el bienestar es algo
que ha ocurrido que ya va a venir así
como por arte de magia
sin embargo la investigación lo que
indica es que las personas que se
encuentran en el polo del bienestar son
personas que hacen cosas de forma
proactiva para sentirse bien
tampoco ayuda la idea de pensar que hoy
no es un buen día para ocuparme de mi
bienestar
y yo me pregunto y si no es ahora cuándo
tengo que espera estar en el polo del
malestar para hacer algo al respecto
si yo estoy experimentando mucho de los
síntomas que están en este arco iris que
más estoy esperando
afortunadamente buenas noticias hace 100
años las personas morían en sus trabajos
60 de cada 100 mil trabajadores fallecía
cada año en accidentes laborales
hasta la década del 40 la jornada de
trabajo era superior a las 60 horas
semanales
hasta hace menos de 50 años preocuparnos
por el bienestar emocional de los
trabajadores era simplemente disparatado
que hoy estemos hablando de estos temas
es un signo de progreso
de hecho son cada vez más los países que
desarrollan legislaciones para cuidar la
salud mental de sus trabajadores y cada
vez son más las organizaciones que
ubican al bienestar como un valor
estratégico
sabio por ejemplo que en holanda es
ilegal que tu jefe te llame después del
horario trabajo
ok en dinamarca te puedes tomar una
semana de vacaciones por mes
o que en españa en los centro de
atención primaria se ofrece un servicio
denominado sicab un protocolo que ayuda
a las personas a regular estos patrones
de pensamiento
y que en sólo siete sesiones ayuda a
disminuir los síntomas de depresión y
ansiedad
y sí sí ya sé que parece bueno pero
nosotros también argentina
acá hay una crisis no podemos darnos el
lujo de pensar en nuestro bienestar
y hay que esperar que no haya crisis en
argentina para tomarnos en serio este
tema
no es acaso la crisis un motivo para
darle prioridad al bienestar emocional
de la población
el bienestar no es un lujo
es un derecho que tenemos que cuidar
entre todos
y una responsabilidad colectiva e
individual
el momento de pensar el bienestar es
ahora
[Aplausos]
aquí
[Música]